i'm going to start with this scientific
critic
a fellow who made a video 45 minute
video on about seven of my videos he
criticized my notion of the scientific
method and i'm answering one point at a
time he just mentioned too many
issues okay brought up a lot of issues
and so i'm going to address one issue at
a time today i'm going to address the
issue that he raised it's related to
evidence
so let me get that video rolling you're
going to hear him
with his own words you know he's going
to tell you what his problem is with
evidence so here goes okay
give me a second here let me turn it on
okay here it goes
the questions and issues addressed in
this rebuttal include
what is evidence and
does evidence play any role in science
for example he says that science is
about rational explanations
and yeah you'll have to have a
hypothesis but their hypothesis doesn't
mean anything if it doesn't align with
the evidence what bill doesn't seem to
get is that evidence is the important
thing in science not the hypothesis
let me run that one more time i got a
little behind on that so one more time
here for everybody who missed it
the questions and issues addressed in
this rebuttal include
what is evidence and
does evidence play any role in science
for example he says that science is
about rational explanations and yeah
you'll have to have a hypothesis but
their hypothesis doesn't mean anything
if it doesn't align with the evidence
what bill doesn't seem to get is that
evidence is the important thing in
science not the hypothesis
okay
so the issue is evidence okay he says
that evidence plays an important role in
science but even before that we have the
issue of the word hypothesis what the
hell is a hypothesis he thinks it's a an
explanation he thinks a hypothesis is a
tentative theory okay tentative
explanation
so here's the rundown on uh how we
address that the first thing is that uh
in the religion of mathematics right
hypothesis is an explanation in science
a hypothesis is an assumption
assumption includes the objects you're
going to use you have to make an
assumption about the invisible objects
that mother nature father universe the
devil god whoever you believe in
what they use to do their phys their
physical things every day you know
they're ordinary uh working you want to
explain gravity you got to figure out
what invisible entities
mother nature uses to do this phenomena
and so one of the things is that a
hypothesis includes the objects the
other one includes the definitions you
need to have a series of definitions so
that people can understand what you're
talking about okay
and then the other one is the what we
call the statement of the facts not the
facts
facts is what mother nature knows he's
got a file cabinet out there with all
the things that happened we have no
access to that file cabinet all we can
do is make a statement of what we think
is in that cabinet statement of the
facts we call it those form the
hypothesis those are three main points
of a hypothesis okay so we have a
problem there already we have a
difference with what this uh fellow
learned that uh harvard cambridge oxford
maybe st andrews university
all these uh are just monasteries they
just teach the same thing that they
learned from the previous generation
okay that's the first issue then we have
an issue of uh you know
here you have it uh
uh for example someone prevent presents
evidence they're gonna present evidence
and what does a prosecutor do he
presents a feather
and you say where does he present a
feather well he's going to prove to the
jury okay this is the prosecutor he's
talking to the jury he's going to
present a feather and he says that
feather belongs to an angel because he's
going to say his argument is that the
angel caused gravity okay and he
presents evidence a feather okay and
here it is okay here's a illustration of
that here you have the uh prosecutor
presenting a feather to the jury because
he says that uh gravity or magnetism or
whatever is done with angels
okay now is that good evidence are we
going to accept that uh as part of the
theory of how gravity works
and here you have the modern version you
say well you don't believe in angels
fine okay do you believe in space-time
okay here we have warp space time what
is he going to present
uh warp time
are we talking about here you know you
have gravity probe b
according to nasa's project 1970s they
say that they sent the probe out there
that had a gyroscope this gyroscope uh
supposedly and here you gotta you know
sit down to really understand what
they're talking about they say that what
the gyroscope did was drag
space-time around itself okay they say
they what's known as frame dragging okay
so here's here's a little gyroscope and
it's gonna drag space time around itself
uh is that evidence is that the evidence
you're you're looking for to understand
how gravity works okay so we have a
problem because here we these people are
presenting evidence maybe evidence of a
you know a feather or maybe warped time
and with that they're going to say
that's the evidence that uh that
explains how gravity works out there
what sense does that make
and then we have another issue with
evidence and that's that evidence has to
do with belief
you know i present evidence what is the
purpose of that evidence it's uh in
you know the purpose of it is to
um induce you to change your way of
thinking i'm trying to recruit you to my
way of thinking that's what i'm doing
with evidence that's what a prosecutor
does that's what a priest does you know
he presents evidence maybe the bible or
whatever and says i want you to believe
like i do
that's what evidence is all about i mean
here you have the jury and they convict
a guy and they send them to the gallows
and it turns out ten years later because
of dna or whatever new evidence it turns
out he was innocent or they
determined that he was not guilty so
what does that mean about the first
evidence was that evidence
proof that the guy was uh you know
guilty and now there's new evidence that
shows that he's not guilty
and again you can see that
we have a problem with evidence and then
there's a final issue there that you
know what evidence are you going to
present for an invisible intangible
entity
an object is not that which you can see
or touch an object is that which has
shape you cannot necessarily see and
touch every object in the universe you
certainly cannot see the air you cannot
touch the table the klingon has on the
other side of the universe so clearly
see touch are irrational uh criteria to
define the word object an object is that
which has shape and that does not mean
that does not entail that you can see
and touch it okay so now you have an
invisible intangible entity okay that
mother nature father universe whoever
has out there
what what evidence can you present
please tell me give me a clue what
evidence i can present for an invisible
intangible entity that will prove to you
that will convince you that yeah that's
exactly how mother nature does gravity
so this is the issue evidence is a
problem okay it's a problem because
first of all it's got to do with belief
second
you cannot use evidence to elucidate the
nature of an invisible intangible entity
and then you know it's uh one of those
things that even if i present evidence
like you know in the case of the gravity
probe
project what am i going to do present uh
wipe time what kind of evidence is that
am i going to present a feather to prove
to you that an angel does gravity so
this is where the problem is so now this
fellow is uh mistaken
uh we do not present evidence in science
what we do in science we present a
theory an explanation of what of how we
think gravity works and the purpose is
not for you to believe the purpose is
for you to understand it
and then you reach your own conclusions
in your own dark basement
that's the way science works
you